it would be so hard to go back home
after everything happened and try to
just live your life normally I think
that's partly why like my family just
chose not to really talk about it
they just wanted to leave it all in the
past
[Music]
during World War 2 Manzano was an
American incarceration camp in which
japanese-americans were held against
their will in the name of national
security
I want to go to Manzanar because I don't
think I know my own history that we'll
both of my grandparents were held in
camps when they are children my family
didn't really talk about it growing up
whenever I'd ask about it like my
grandparents were too young to remember
and they said that they never talked
about it with their parents my family
was actually not in the camps it was
more like just remember this is also
something that happened here in
California which I'm born and raised in
California I want to come out of this
you know more knowledgeable but also I
want to come out of this with a greater
understanding of what happened I want to
understand what it felt like and
understand what they had to go through
something like the story of the camps
like visiting the camps being there
talking to people about it like amongst
ourselves as japanese-americans
understand the garland story is so key
because we're not going to be able to
move forward if we don't know where we
came from
[Music]
when the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor
our West Coast became a potential combat
zone living in that zone where more than
a hundred thousand persons of Japanese
ancestry military authorities therefore
determined that all of them citizens and
aliens alike would have to move the
evacuate cooperated wholeheartedly the
many loyal among them felt that this was
a sacrifice they could make in behalf of
America's worid
[Music]
the air felt clean but also like you're
in the middle of nowhere like almost
like place lessness torn right out here
yeah very hot little hot nice you go
well thanks to this amazing amazing
manger comes to meet us and she she uh
sure's us over to the barracks a lot of
Manzanar is gone so most of the original
buildings are gone manzanar wouldn't
even be here for us to visit if it
weren't for the efforts of
japanese-americans who made the
pilgrimage back to the site and then who
successfully lobbied the government to
preserve it these barracks
i've been rebuilt in the same spot that
the ones were doing war world war ii the
barracks here were under feet by 20 feet
when you got here you were given an army
blanket and canvas sack actually less
better made than this and told to go
outside with a pile of hay and stuff it
now is your mattress you have a people
who are in the camps come through the
spirit what's the usual their immediate
reaction is this is too nice there's
just like bunch of Japanese / Japanese
Americans that were squished into a very
small space continued journey yeah I
live in the studio apartment and when my
mom and sister can you say
I can't imagine not comfortable when
they came here how long were they told
they're gonna be staying they didn't
know the phrase was for the duration
that must be tough to not be able to
tell your kids how long they have to
expect to stay I just kept thinking
about the first night imagine the first
night walking into this barrack imagine
the first night with your suitcase just
like unpacked of the foot of your bed
unsure how long you're going to be there
we went outside and well we were on the
grounds we did notice that there were
like basketball courts this basketball
court has been redone but it is
historically correct some of the rocks
are where they were 70 years ago seeing
the basketball hoops there just proves
that despite all the injustice and
things that were being placed upon them
they didn't break their spirit ball was
still life which is like super dope to
me we went into the visitor center and I
was really fascinating obviously seeing
like all of the propaganda from the time
but from a nationally syndicated
columnist who said heard him up pack
them off and give them the inside room
in the badlands let him be pinched hurt
hungry and dead up against it personally
I hate the Japanese and that goes for
all of them looks so big like the full
camp itself what we saw was just one
little section but
just like insane masses the Ranger took
out these family records for those of us
who have families that were putting the
camps GJ this list where they're the
families from obviously that my
grandma's family was from part of
California and this list where they're
heading to where after they leave camp
where they're going and if you look at
this is all my family Chicago Illinois
Chicago Illinois Chicago Illinois I mean
they made it there because that's where
I'm from seeing it on paper and seeing
like the actual record like that's like
a piece of my family's history right
there you know like an artifact Shawn I
found both your grandparents block
addresses which we want to try to go see
them I would probably have better luck
than you did so block five is is the one
where Paul was yeah
[Music]
this is where my grandpa's barrack was
[Music]
yeah they hadn't excavated the site so
our park ranger told us that the plate
had probably been at that barrack site
for over 70 years gonna put it back yes
take only photos leave all the concepts
the morning before we went to Manzanar
was the first time that my grandfather
forgot my name and so to be at Manzanar
the next day and to see his barrack I
think for me it was like survivors of
the camps can't be the only ones telling
the story because they're fading but for
us to make sure that the lessons
continue we have to keep going back to
the camps where they're literally or
figuratively cuz there's so much to
learn it looks like I really do think it
was probably a sewer pipe this is
definitely I told you as a sewer class
the diameter is too big so water coming
in has to be in pressure so you get
those smaller lines I am probably
holding a sewage pipe
you
we went to the cemetery and that was
just very like peaceful and serene it's
just covered and he's like colorful like
origami crane and there is this like
wind storm blowing and I was like
blowing the crane the whole thing in
general was actually a lot more
emotional for me than I thought it would
be I thought I would see it you know
from like a historical perspective I
didn't expect it to affect me like it
did when you learn something about a
tragedy the next step is sort of like oh
what work can be done in order to apply
the lessons from camp there's like this
real danger that like this same rhetoric
is going to get out there and that
people are going to be arbitrarily like
sent off for for no reason just imagine
someone just telling you to pack your
bag and leave right now it's nobody's
duty to read every textbook and take a
vision right day's course and learn
everything just showing up it's not like
saving the world but I think that it's
by knowing more and by learning more and
by gaining knowledge and then building a
perspective or ultimately contributing
to a larger consciousness
[Music]